-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy
and Emmy Award-nominated actor
you know from films such as
"Closer," "Sin City,"
and "Children of Men"
and shows like "The Knick"
and "A Murder
at the End of the World."
He stars in "Monsieur Spade,"
which airs Sunday nights on AMC.
Let's take a look.
-Maybe you forgot you were
going to stay off my property.
-Your property.
-Oh, Jesus.
Have you been
sitting there since last night?
-What are you talking about?
I wasn't here last night.
-Then who was?
-How would I know?
I wasn't here.
-Philippe Saint Andre --
did you lend him your bike?
-Sometimes, he just takes it.
He's an old friend, after all.
-Oh.
With friends like that,
who needs friends?
Jean-Pierre, there's some things
you just don't ever want to do.
-Please welcome back to
the show Clive Owen, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome back, Clive.
I'm so happy to have you here.
-Oh, I'm happy to be here.
-You were last here in 2015,
which is a while ago,
and we were talking
about your beloved
football club, Liverpool.
-Yes.
-They weren't doing
too well in 2015,
but, you know,
not bad this year.
-Better than not bad.
Top of the league.
I think we're in with a shot.
-Alright. Very exciting.
Do you ever get a chance
to go to games anymore?
-I do. Yeah, yeah.
I go when I can, yeah.
-Alright. And do they --
Are they excited to see you
or they just care
what's on the pitch
and they don't care
about you at all?
-No, they don't
care about me at all.
-Okay, that's good.
Helps keep you grounded.
-Yeah.
-This is very --
This is a really cool project.
It's a very cool idea.
This is the very famous
film noir detective Sam Spade,
famously played in
"The Maltese Falcon"
by Humphrey Bogart.
But this is a different
part of his life.
-Yeah. So, what we've done is,
we've jumped 20 years ahead.
He's living in
the South of France.
And you have some flashbacks
of how he ended up there
and what the situation is.
He's trying to live the quiet
life in the South of France,
and then, at the end
of the first episode,
we unearth something terrible
has happened,
and the old Sam Spade's
going to have to come back out.
-That's always the way
with these retired detectives.
Something always brings you out.
I read a really funny --
a comment you had
in a profile of Scott Frank,
who's the wonderful writer
who created the show,
about how he sold you
on the idea of playing
Sam Spade,
which is so exciting,
and then maybe left out that
it was 20 years in the future.
-20 years in the future,
took away the hat,
took away the mac,
took away the smoking,
took away the gun.
So my running gag
with him was, "Duped.
I've been duped."
Like, I need to go off and find
another noir project to do,
because this isn't the one.
-Now, I will say,
one way he didn't dupe you --
South of France.
-Yeah.
-You were also wonderful in
"A Murder at
the End of the World."
That's Iceland.
I feel like you deserved
a nice South of France project.
-Oh, it's true, to go from,
yeah, the very cold
to the lovely South of France.
-Yeah. Well,
it's a beautiful show,
it looks beautiful,
And I would assume it was
as nice to be there
as it looks on camera.
-It was fantastic.
Yeah, it was really idyllic.
It was beautiful.
-Was that a movie --
"Maltese Falcon" --
I mean, obviously, neither of us
were around when it came out,
but I remember where I found it
in a video store.
What was your first experience
with that movie?
-I'm crazy about that movie.
I actually have an original
poster of that movie.
Like, I adore that movie.
And I would have
seen that in the --
I was at drama school
in the early '80s,
and there was about
three or four
great rep cinemas that showed,
like, regularly,
old, classic movies,
and I spent a lot of time
going and catching up
with the classics.
-When you play a character
like that
that was so iconically played
by Humphrey Bogart,
like, do you try to remember it
or try to forget about it
when you're on set?
-I think, you know, what
you're supposed to do is go,
"I'm going to go
and put my stamp on it
and do my interpretation,"
but I am such a Bogart fan
that I used it as an opportunity
to go drink him in
and lean right into that,
because although
we've jumped 20 years ahead,
the origins of him
is that San Francisco
private detective from the '40s,
and I wanted that flavor
to still be sort of simmering
through everything.
-That's a really fun thing
to be able to bring to a role,
like, just to not just research
the character on the page,
but also know that there
was also this performance
that you can pull from.
-I adore Bogart, and, like,
you know, it's the cliché,
but "Casablanca" is my
all-time favorite movie.
-It's kind of a perfect movie.
It does not age badly.
Everything about it is great.
So, speaking of old
movie theaters, so, this is,
I guess, Electric Palace.
Is that actually
what it's known as?
-Yeah.
-And, so, you -- Tell me
about this beautiful old cinema.
You're involved with it.
-So, yeah, I've got a place
that's very near there,
and it's in this small town
called Harwich.
And I've got a history
with the cinema.
I remember the first time I went
with my wife so many years ago,
there was only
the two of us in there,
and they were
playing "Moonstruck."
And and the girl
came up and said,
"Oh, we've got a rule here.
If there's not six people,
we don't screen it."
And I, quick as a flash,
said, "Well, I'll pay for six."
And they said, "No,
if you're going to do that,
we're going to screen it."
So I watched "Moonstruck"
with my wife there on our own,
when we were very early dating.
But then they asked me
to become a patron,
and I've helped them out a lot
and I've sort of
helped them raise money,
got them funding
to keep the place going.
It was built in 1911.
It's still as it was then.
And after I got this job,
I got in contact with them
and I did
a "Maltese Falcon"/"Casablanca"
double bill to a full cinema.
So, I like, in the end,
you were like,
"I'll pay for
four extra tickets."
They're like, "Absolutely not."
And then it sounds like they've
just gotten thousands from you.
-[ Laughs ]
-You thought
they were being polite.
They were like,
"We got him on the hook."
-What goes around comes around.
-There you go. There you go.
South of France --
How is your French?
I mean, you have to do it a
little bit. I got nervous.
My mom's a French teacher,
and I got nervous about
saying "Monsieur Spade."
So how about you?
-No. I mean,
I was asked at the beginning,
"How's your French?
Is it good?"
I said, "It will be."
-Oh, that's very nice.
That's a real good actor answer.
-I tried to learn it
classically and realized
I was spending so much time
learning things
that I wasn't going to need.
Like, I'm not going
to be tested.
I don't need the grammar.
So I learned it phonetically.
I learned it like
an accent and by sounds.
-Oh, that's fantastic.
-Yeah.
-And do you feel like
it was better
when you left
the South of France?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I like that now --
I like that, beforehand,
you're like, "I'll know it
by the time I get on set."
Now that the job's over,
you're like, "Nope."
That's when you find out a real
honest answer from an actor
is when the job's over.
Didn't speak it,
didn't get better.
I don't have to do it again.
It's a really cool show,
and it's so nice
to have you back here.
Thanks so much, Clive.
-It's a pleasure. Thank you.
-Clive Owen, everybody.
"Monsieur Spade"
airs Sundays on AMC
and streams on AMC+
and Acorn TV,
and "A Murder
at the End of the World --"
also fantastic --
streaming on Hulu now.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with
Isla Fisher.